what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right pelina is annoying me today
as usual no problem
wall street i already said that don't
worry that
forget wow what a start
thursday one day till friday
block five is now the sponsor of lunch
money you can go to block five.com
pomp what is it oh blockfy.com
pomp wow thursday energy coming out of
you no worries
trillionaire energy coming out of me as
always if you want to earn up to 8.6
percent apy and an interest bearing
account go to blockfit.com you can also
sign up for the waitlist for the bitcoin
rewards credit card go get it bitcoin
blockfy.com pomp if i can't speak
english by the end of this
do not be surprised let's go new
applications for us unemployment
benefits
rose in late march but they're likely to
be begin
oh wow type two to begin falling again
soon as the economy revs up government
solution
pandemic related restrictions and
companies seek to hire more workers
they have jumped to 719
000 what is this spike about is it just
temporary
these people are idiots that's that's
what happens
719 000 people last
week in one week filed for first-time
unemployment claims
that before this pandemic would have
been
one of the highest rates of unemployment
in a
single week in history
yet we're talking about oh it's no
problem it's coming down blah blah blah
are you guys kidding me and by the way
the narrative a couple of weeks ago was
oh
unemployment's falling new job claims
are falling well now they're rising
again
so is it their falling or is it that
this is a temporary spike yeah i feel
like i've read
a variation of this headline like 18
billion times already
the problem is that they still have
parts of the economy locked down
the vaccine is here they started with
crushed the curve then it was the
vaccine
open it up let people go back to work if
people are scared if they're old if they
have pre-existing conditions we can
protect them
but open up the economy and allow people
to go to work so that we do not have
719 000
people that's wild for the first time
filing for unemployment claims
because remember that means that those
people
didn't file since last march for the
last year they survived but now 719
000 last week finally capitulated and
had to file
how many is it going to be this week
hopefully not as many
but we don't know robin hood is getting
rid of the confetti
animation that appears on user screen
after they conduct their first trade
and achieve other milestones the change
comes as the app faces growing scrutiny
over what critics say is a gamification
of trading
that masks the potential for real losses
in the financial markets
now as we discussed yesterday we don't
know anybody
who is trading on robinhood
just to see that confetti screen not
only that
but the confetti happens after you trade
so if you remove the confetti it's not
like you prevent them from trading
literally they trade then the confetti
happens
so removing the confetti is kind of more
of a virtual signaling move
than it is actually trying to change
user behavior
if you want to change user behavior make
it harder to trade
don't simply remove this thing that they
don't know is gonna happen until after
they trade i don't know and i know that
like that's a very valid
concern and question for robin hood i
don't see it in any of these articles
that i'm reading nobody was like hey by
the way
why don't you make it harder to trade if
that's the behavior you want to
uh decrease it's because they don't
actually want to make it harder to trade
by the way which is their right
they are a private company that is going
to go public supposedly
uh and their whole business is
predicated on making it easier to trade
i think what they should do instead is
say listen
we're not gonna make it harder we
actually want people to
have this seamless way to trade we
believe gamification is the future which
obviously they believe and we don't care
what the critics say
go and trade and use our product if you
don't want to use our product go use a
different product let the free market
rain stop capitulating
to the critics and to the masses i love
it because that's what's happening right
here
is literally robin hood is taking a step
back and they're saying oh we'll give
you this thing we'll take away the
confetti
either don't do anything or actually do
the things that are going to have a
material change
on the business and the user behavior
doing this kind of halfway mark it's
like you're trying to appease
the critics without actually changing
the problem or fixing the problem
frontier airlines as parent company said
it raised 570 million dollars in an ipo
the latest u.s carrier to take that
route as the industry
starts to see signs of a recovery from
the coveted pandemic so did frontier not
get a bailout
uh does it say no
um i think that they probably got
something whether it was a bailout
whether it was ppp loans whether it was
uh
payroll support they probably got
something it would be hard to believe
that
uh an airline made it through the last
12 months uh and while all of their
peers and competitors
took money they took zero that seems a
little bit difficult
but again it goes back this is what we
should have done last year is rather
than the government create all of this
money through quantitative easing
and going ahead and handing out cash to
everyone especially the airline industry
they should have said to the airlines
you have access to the debt and equity
capital markets
go and raise money if you or take a loan
if you need debt go to the debt markets
if you need equity capital go to the
equity markets
but don't come to the us government
begging for free money that's what
happened
is the government gave free money to a
bunch of these airlines
i think it was uh one-third of all the
money that they gave
was for free you don't have to pay it
back there's no interest
and they didn't get any equity for it so
they literally just
printed or created money and then handed
it to all these airlines
what's up with that all right so
did they take any money i couldn't find
okay uh so get this
slack ceo stuart butterfield
went on clubhouse to speak the other
speaker in the room
was clubhouse founder uh paul
paul what is paul's last name paul
davidson okay
and stewart the ceo of slack
made his announcement on clubhouse in a
chat with
davison saying i've always believed the
good that
the good artists copy great artist steel
thing so we're just building clubhouse
into slack essentially
and he gave a quick rundown of all the
clubhouse features he planned to
replicate
on his larger and better funded platform
and then wrapped up
by saying so look out for clubhouse
built into slack
i wonder how paul responded to that talk
that smack let's go
here i'd be like get off my platform
stewart no
this is exactly what should happen this
is how free markets work
allow slack to do whatever they want
yeah if you've got the superior pro if
you've got the superior product
then go and beat them go beat them is
that what you if you were paul how would
you respond to stuart
i would say great congratulations you
should go do that you should go build
that into slack by the way we have
something completely different
that we're trying to build right with
all the creators etc but here's what is
going to end up happening
it's the same thing like with instagram
stories whoever has the bigger network
they win and slack realizes they have
this massive network
slack first of all is going to allow you
to chat with anybody on the slack
platform not just the people in your
slack room
but they're soon going to allow let's
say plano worked at one company i work
at a different company
and we're not the same slack room i
could then message planet directly
so that now slack becomes like a social
network essentially
then the second thing is that they build
in things like clubhouse functionality
etc
drop in audio is a feature on most
platforms it is not
an entire product we'll see but i i
actually think cloudhouse has a good
chance of being a very very successful
business
it's been a great time to be selling
really really expensive
cars super expensive cars like for
ferraris ferraris bentleys and
lamborghinis
finished 2020 at a blistering pace
during the pandemic sales have risen
over in the united states overall
passenger car sales were down 10
last year compared to 2019 but
cars sales of cars costing more than 80
thousand dollars were almost double in
the fourth quarter what they had been
the year before
bang bang let's roll the booming stock
market has played a big part
and since the wealthy haven't been able
to spend money on trips many have turned
to luxury goods like expensive cars
let's go i love to see it
if you understand anything about assets
luxury goods serve as great stores of
value cars not so much depreciating
asset but for the most part when people
get super super rich like what's
happening right now as they
create all this money and push up asset
prices no yawning on the show we've
already been over this
then what people will do is they will go
and they will buy luxury goods luxury
homes luxury bags luxury cars and if you
own
or sell ferraris bugattis bentleys
corvettes
porsches corvettes lamborghinis ooh
lamborghinis okay you probably don't do
well
guys we've gone an entire episode
without telling you this
today april 1st 2021
is exactly one year since we aired the
first lunch money episode
so if you have been here since day one
congratulations
it has been a year april fool no just
kidding it really it really has been one
year
although some could argue it was march
31st but that's when he did it by
himself and i joined on april 4 so
that's the real start date
nerd okay it's ask lunch money time
i couldn't find a good question so today
we only have a moist update what's up
voice says
day 90 of commenting then hahaha sending
the dm with my email right now
and we did not email him so what do we
do moist
i told you to stay out of my wife's dms
with your cell phone number
and then i heard that you dm'd or your
number strike
one we've gone all this time
and now all of a sudden you're screwing
around i will email
moist today i think i may
even title the email dear moist
so what are what are you going to tell
him that's for me and him to
have our conversations that a b
conversation so see your way out of here
i'll come back to everyone with a little
moist update wet soggy
sorry we we've appreciated you so much
on this
long journey maybe i'll do a little
three-way call
goodbye
[Laughter]
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends